- [Instructor] Welcome.
Today, we're going to take
a look at forms of energy,
such as kinetic, electrical, thermal,
gravitational, potential energy.
It turns out when you start thinking
about energy on smaller scales,
or the microscopic level,
all of these forms of energy
are basically two things:
one, kinetic energy,
particles moving around,
and two, potential energy,
energy stored by a field,
such as electric,
magnetic or gravitational.
Let's start with a
deceivingly simple example
and explore properties
of energy as we zoom in.
I'm drawing a glass of water.
This water has a temperature.
I can warm up the water by adding energy
from an electric stove,
or cool down the water by
putting it in the fridge,
thus removing energy in the liquid water.
From this example, we
can see that temperature
is related to energy.
But how is it related to
kinetic or potential energy?
Hmm.
This big picture, the macroscopic scale,
allows us to look at energy
in terms of temperature.
But let's go to the
microscopic or small-scale
to get a better picture
of the physics at play.
As we look inside this liquid,
we see lots of water
molecules moving around.
Zoom, zoom, zoom.
Well, they don't actually make a sound.
The average speed at
which these molecules move
is related to their kinetic
energy and its temperature.
This is thermal motion.
If we zoom in again, we can
look into the strong chemical
bonds within molecules.
Here, the individual atoms,
in this case for water,
is hydrogen and oxygen.
They can vibrate back
and forth and rotate,
so they also have kinetic energy.
Let's look at another example
between macro and microscale
energy interactions.
When you burn something, think of a fire.
A chemical reaction takes place,
and it releases a lot of energy.
How does it do that?
Let's look at the microscopic
scale to find out.
In this example, I'm
gonna burn methane gas,
and the chemical reaction that takes place
is methane, CH4, and oxygen, O2.
They rearrange to create water, H2O,
and carbon dioxide, CO2, plus energy.
Before the reaction,
there is a greater
chemical potential energy
than afterwards.
But don't worry.
Energy is still conserved
because that potential energy
is converted to kinetic
energy and radiation.
What is the source of
chemical potential energy?
At this level, we can
think of individual bonds
between atoms storing energy
so that energy can be absorbed or released
as bonds are broken and reformed.
But where does the energy
and chemical bonds come from?
We need to zoom in again.
In a single atom,
there's a nucleus that
contains protons and neutrons
and overall has a positive charge.
This creates an electromagnetic field.
The interaction of
other charged particles,
like negatively charged electrons
relatively far away from the nucleus,
with this field provide potential energy.
You can think of this
electric potential energy
as the same kind of concept
as a potential energy
of a mass and a gravitational field.
Zooming back out, each
molecule has its own
particular configuration
of charged particles
within the electromagnetic fields, right?
This means it has an
associated potential energy.
As we've seen, this
chemical potential energy
is the result of energy stored in fields.
Okay, so we've covered
electrical, chemical,
thermal types of energy,
but there's other forms out there, right?
For instance, what about sound waves?
Here's a speaker and an ear.
The energy in sound waves is transferred
through the vibrations,
a back and forth motion
of molecules in the air.
Another example could be
elastic potential energy
or the energy stored in a spring.
At the microscopic level,
as you stretch the spring,
see the hand stretching the spring?
The atoms are being pulled out
of their equilibrium position
within a solid and thus
gain potential energy
from the electromagnetic force
that holds the solid together.
How neat is this?
We can describe all these energies
as just kinetic or potential.
So there's one more
microscopic form of energy
that we need to talk about,
and it might seem a little
complicated at first.
Let's go back to the combustion example
we talked about earlier.
As I said before, this process
releases radiant energy.
We can see burning objects.
They glow brightly.
We can also put our hand
near the burning object.
Don't touch it!
And feel the radiant heat.
This radiation that's emitted
carries energy with it.
So how do we explain the radiant energy?
Does it fit it into one
of these two categories,
either kinetic or potential energy
that we've been discussing?
Well, it turns out it sort
of fits into both groups.
Whoa, electromagnetic
radiation, such as light,
can be modeled in a
couple of different ways,
which we'll go into more
detail in another video.
But one way to model the light
is as a wave of electric
and magnetic fields.
Another way to think about light
is being made up of
particles called photons.
In this instance, the particles
are carrying the energy.
So with both of these models,
radiant energy can be explained
by the same microscopic interactions
that cause the other forms of energy.
In conclusion, we can see
energy at the macroscopic scale,
like temperature or light being emitted.
However, we must look at the microscale
to observe the different forms of energy
that we experience are
really just the result
of kinetic and potential
energy of particles.
How cool!